Here's one of the strangest outcomes in a courtroom I have heard about in a while. And it contains a lesson that very well might come in handy for you, and I do mean you, some day in your own life. Jake Halpern was the reporter who witnessed this. It was in a courtroom in Georgia. He was down there researching a book about credit card debt.
我刚才听到一个最近最不可思议的法庭裁决。它包含了一个很有用的道理，将来可能在某一天对你——我确实是指你——的生活派上用场。杰克·霍尔珀恩（Jake Halpern）是亲眼目睹此事的记者。事情发生在佐治亚州的一个法庭里。他在那里做调研，写一本关于信用卡债务的书。
This is called-- in Georgia, they call it magistrate court. And it's basically small claims court. And you go in and it's all debtors. People refer to it even as debtors court.
这叫——在佐治亚州，他们称之为治安法官法庭。其实就是小额索偿法庭。你走进去，里面全是债务人。人们甚至管它叫债务人法庭。
So Jake meets a couple sitting there, Frederick and Keanne. They're in their 40s, nicely dressed. She's a shoe salesman. He's an ex-marine who had a business buying houses, rehabbing them, and then selling them, which was going great till the housing market fell apart in 2008, and then that kind of went to hell for a while. They ended up taking on some debt. And then they got a notice in the mail saying that they owed money to a company called LVNV Funding, which is what brought them to court.
杰克遇到了坐在那儿的一对夫妇，弗雷德里克（Frederick）和基安（Keanne）。他们四十多岁，衣着得体。妻子是鞋店销售员，丈夫是前海军陆战队队员，曾经做过房屋买卖和翻修生意，但在2008年房地产市场崩溃前一切都很顺利，之后那阵子生意就一落千丈。他们最终背负了一些债务。后来他们收到一封信，说欠一家叫LVNV Funding的公司钱，这就是他们出现在法庭的原因。
And Keanne, at this point, says, like, I don't even know who LVNV Funding is. And one of the reasons that she says I'm here today in court is just to figure out what this is all about, because she doesn't even recognize them as being her creditor.
这时，基安说，我甚至都不知道LVNV Funding是谁。她说今天来法庭的一个原因就是想搞清楚这到底是怎么回事，因为她根本没把对方当作自己的债权人。
How much are they on the hook for?
他们背负了多少债务？
They're on the hook for $3,762.20. So we're sitting there talking, and this young guy in a suit all of a sudden calls out their name. And, for a moment, it's not clear who exactly he is. And he calls it out in a way that almost like an official would call out your name. And they're-- they start walking over to talk to this guy.
他们背负了3762.20美元的债务。我们坐在那里聊天，一个穿西装的年轻人突然叫了他们的名字。一时间，不清楚他到底是谁。他叫人的方式几乎就像官员传唤你的名字一样。他们开始走过去和那个人谈话。
So this young guy quickly says I'm the lawyer representing the people that own your debt. Are you Keanne? Are you Frederick? And then he looks at me and is like and who are you.
那个年轻人很快说，我是代表你们债务所有者的律师。你是基安吗？你是弗雷德里克吗？然后他看着我问，那你又是谁。
Jake explains that he's a reporter, he's researching a book. The guy replies--
杰克解释说他是记者，正在调研一本书。那人回答——
Well, I'm not comfortable with you being here. And Frederick was like, well, we are comfortable with him being here. And there's this like moment, and then this lawyer just rolls his eyes and just continues with his pitch to them.
我不欢迎你在场。弗雷德里克说，我们欢迎他在场。僵持了一会儿，律师翻了个白眼，继续向他们推销。
Frederick and Keanne tell the lawyer that they're confused. They don't know who this NVLV Funding is or what the debt is. And the lawyer says that his client owns their American Express debt. Basically, when Frederick and Keanne failed to pay of their American Express bill, American Express sold the IOU to this company. And they're trying to collect it.
弗雷德里克和基安告诉律师他们很困惑。他们不知道NVLV Funding是谁，也不知道这笔债务是怎么回事。律师说他的客户拥有他们的美国运通（American Express）债务。基本上，当弗雷德里克和基安没能支付美国运通的账单时，美国运通把这笔借条卖给了这家公司。他们现在正试图讨债。
Obviously, that's a big business. There are lots of companies that do this. The lawyer asks them--
显然，这是一门大生意。有很多公司都在做这个。律师问他们——
You did have an American Express card, correct? And they say, yeah, we had American Express card. And you do live at-- and he gives their address. Yes. Well, this is what you owe.
你们确实有美国运通信用卡，对吧？他们说，是的，我们有。你们住在——他报出了他们的地址。对。这就是你们欠的钱。
And then he reaches into his briefcase and he pulls out this piece of paper, which I'm actually holding in front of me. I brought it along. At first glance, it resembles a credit card statement, like the ones that we get every month that says what you owe.
然后他从公文包里拿出一张纸，我现在正拿在手里。我把它带过来了。乍一看，它像是一份信用卡账单，就像我们每个月收到的那种显示你欠款多少的账单。
But then, at the top, and you look and-- it says at the very top of it, this is an account summary. It is not a credit card statement from the original creditor and has not previously been provided to the consumer. So it-- it's really bizarre right off the start because they're handing this thing that's clearly been set up to resemble a credit card statement, and yet there it says right at the top, but this is not actually a credit card statement.
但你看最上面，写着“账户摘要”。这并非原始债权人提供的信用卡账单，且此前未向消费者提供。所以一开始就很离谱，因为他们递过来的这份东西显然被制作得像是信用卡账单，但最上面却写着这其实并不是信用卡账单。
And so the things you would find on a normal credit card statement, like a list of charges, it doesn't have that, doesn't say how much of this is the original debt and how much is interest. There's nothing that would help you figure out how they got to the number $3,762.20. So Frederick asked the guy if he has anything else to help them make sense of this number. Does he have the original contract from when they took out the credit card to prove that, in fact, his client does actually own the debt now and it's all legit?
所以，你在普通信用卡账单上能看到的明细（比如消费列表），这里都没有，也没写清楚多少是原始债务，多少是利息。没有任何信息能帮你算出他们是怎么得出3762.20美元这个数字的。所以弗雷德里克问那人还有没有其他证据来解释这个数字。他有没有他们办理信用卡时的原始合同，来证明他的客户确实拥有这笔债务且一切合法？
The lawyer says he doesn't need to provide any of that. The debt is real, they have to pay. And then Jake pipes up. For his reporting, he's wondering does the lawyer actually have any of that stuff, the original signed contract, or account statements.
律师说他不需要提供任何这些东西。债务是真实的，他们必须还钱。这时杰克插话了。作为调研，他想知道律师是否真的有那些东西，比如原始签署的合同或账户明细。
So the lawyer turns back to me and he says, are you representing them? And I said, no, no, I'm just curious. And he's like, well, you can't represent them, you're not a lawyer. And Frederick's like, he's not representing us. He just asked the same question that I did.
于是律师转过身对我说，你是他们的代理人吗？我说，不，不，我只是好奇。他说，你不能代理他们，你又不是律师。弗雷德里克说，他没代理我们。他只是问了和我一样的问题。
The lawyer repeats, you can't represent them. And Jake says they go around and around on this for a while. And, finally, it's time to go into a courtroom. And as they walk in, the lawyer taps Jake on the shoulder and tells him, I'm going to put you on the witness stand.
律师重复道，你不能代理他们。杰克说他们在这个问题上纠缠了一会儿。最后，是时候进法庭了。当他们走进去时，律师拍了拍杰克的肩膀，告诉他，我要把你送上证人席。
And I was like OK, like I couldn't tell-- it was just a crazy thing to say. I didn't know if he was just messing with me. Five minutes later, they call Keanne's name out, and then the judge also says, and Jake Halpern, you need to come up here too. So I'm like-- and then it's me and Keanne raising our hands together and being sworn in together, almost like co-defendants. That's the only-- that's the only way I can describe. It's like we're both on trial here.
我就想，好吧，这话说得太疯狂了。我不知道他是不是在耍我。五分钟后，他们叫了基安的名字，法官也说，杰克·霍尔珀恩，你也需要过来。于是我成了那样——我和基安一起举手，一起宣誓，就像共同被告一样。我只能这么描述。就像我们两个都在受审一样。
And you've known Keanne how long at this point?
你认识基安多久了？
I've known her like 10 minutes. And the young lawyer immediately starts with what's his opening argument. And he tells the judge this man right here is representing this couple and he is practicing-- therefore practicing law without a license. And, Your Honor, I need you to inform him that he could face criminal sanctions for doing this.
我认识她也就10分钟。那位年轻律师立即开始了开庭陈词。他告诉法官，这个男的正在代理这对夫妇，因此是在无证执业。法官阁下，我需要您告知他，这样做可能会面临刑事处罚。
Jake tells the judge that he only asked a few questions. And the judge rules, it turns out this is not the same thing as pretending to be a lawyer, so that gets settled. And then they turn to the business at hand. Remember, this entire story I'm telling you is about credit card debt, and what happens in court when a consumer is sued.
杰克告诉法官他只是问了几个问题。法官裁定，这与冒充律师并非一回事，所以事情解决了。然后他们处理正事。记住，我讲的整个故事都是关于信用卡债务，以及消费者被起诉时法庭会发生什么。
And so far, as you see, so far, right, the lawyer is playing hardball. He is not messing around, which makes what happens next even more interesting. The judge turns to the lawyer, and the judge says to the lawyer, so what do you want to do about this debt.
到目前为止，如你所见，律师态度强硬。他不是在开玩笑，这让接下来发生的事变得更有趣。法官转向律师，问他打算怎么处理这笔债务。
And the lawyer then says to the judge, you know what, give me a minute. I need to consult with my client. So he walks out of the courtroom. Me and Keanne and the judge are kind of left in the courtroom. And the lawyer goes out into the hallway, and then comes back like two minutes later, and says, Your Honor, we're going to be dropping this, dismissing the case.
律师对法官说，你知道吗，给我一分钟。我需要咨询我的客户。于是他走出了法庭。我和基安以及法官被留在了法庭里。律师走到走廊上，大约两分钟后回来，说，法官阁下，我们打算撤诉。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And I'm like-- I'm looking at her. And Keanne's looking at me. And we're both like this just makes-- this makes no sense After all this fuss and this full court press you put on us?
对。我看着她，基安也看着我。我们都在想，这完全说不通。大张旗鼓折腾这么久，给我们施加全套法庭压力，结果就这样？
So Jake, and Keanne, and Frederick go into the hallway and they are trying to figure out what in the world just happened. And this lawyer from Georgia Legal Services, who saw this whole thing go down, joins their conversation.
于是杰克、基安和弗雷德里克来到走廊，试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。一位目睹全过程的佐治亚法律援助中心律师加入了他们的谈话。
And he is not in the least bit surprised by this. He's like-- he's like, oh, yeah, of course he dropped the case. And I'm like what do you mean of course he dropped the case. He said, oh, well, when a consumer actually shows up in court and says the magic words, then these cases basically evaporate. And I say, the magic words? He says, yeah, show me the evidence.
他一点也不惊讶。他说，哦，当然，他撤诉了。我说，什么意思叫当然撤诉？他说，噢，当消费者真的出现在法庭上并说出那些“魔法咒语”时，这些案件基本就自动作废了。我说，魔法咒语？他说，对，就是“拿出证据给我看”。
Show me the evidence. In other words, show me where you got this number $3,762.20. The Georgia Legal Services lawyer told Jake that if you're standing before a judge, and you say, OK, I don't recognize this amount that you say I owe and I want to see some documentation, I want to see account statements or whatever, because I have no way to know with certainty that this debt is really mine, the judge will usually turn to the other side and ask for the evidence. And, in all likelihood, they'll have no documentation and they'll drop the case.
“拿出证据给我看”。换句话说，拿出证据证明你是怎么算出3762.20美元这个数字的。那位法律援助律师告诉杰克，如果你站在法官面前说，好吧，我不认可这笔欠款，我想看相关文件，我想看账户明细之类的，因为我无法确定这笔债务真的是我的，法官通常会转向对方要求出示证据。十有八九，他们拿不出任何文件，于是就会撤诉。
And this is true not just in Georgia, but elsewhere. Because the way this business works, Jake says, when credit card companies sell these IOUs to debt collection companies, they usually don't give them any documentation. Usually, they just give them a spreadsheet with a long list of people who owe money on their credit cards, and their addresses, and their last payment, and how much they owe, and not a lot more than that. So when these companies take you and me to court, where they're betting on is we won't show up, which is a really good bet, Jake says, because--
这不仅在佐治亚州如此，其他地方也是。杰克说，因为这门生意的运作方式是，当信用卡公司把这些借条卖给债务催收公司时，通常不会提供任何文件。他们通常只给一张电子表格，上面列着一长串欠信用卡钱的人的名字、地址、最后一次还款时间和欠款金额，除此之外没别的了。所以当这些公司把你我告上法庭时，他们赌的就是我们不会出庭，而这确实是个胜率极高的赌注，杰克说，因为——
The vast majority of people don't actually-- who are debtors who are being sued don't actually show up in court. The no show rate, there's different estimates, but it's between 80% and 90% of people don't show up.
绝大多数被起诉的债务人根本不会出庭。关于不出庭率，虽有不同估算，但大约有80%到90%的人不会出庭。
If they don't show up, they lose. If they showed up, if they said the magic words, they would probably win. And now you know the magic words, you can use them yourself. Though, Jake said, he is not sure that he thinks it's always such a good thing. He talked another guy who had a lot of debt, this is an Indian immigrant who owned a steakhouse and owed like $300,000.
如果他们不出庭，他们就输了。如果他们出庭，说了那些魔法咒语，他们就很可能会赢。现在你知道这些魔法咒语了，你自己也可以用。尽管杰克说，他不确定这是否总是件好事。他采访了另一个人，那个人欠了很多债，是个印度移民，开了一家牛排馆，欠了大约30万美元。
And he had used these magic words almost to the point where it was like a scam, like he owed all this money for this steakhouse that had gone bust. And he was just showing up in court and saying like show me the original signed contracts, show me the statements, and he was like beating these debts left and right. Like Keanne--
他用这些魔法咒语简直到了诈骗的地步，牛排馆破产后他欠了一屁股债。他只是出现在法庭上说，把原始签署的合同拿给我看，把账单拿给我看，结果他接二连三地摆脱了这些债务。就像基安——
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
He was working it. Like, oh, my god, there's this magic button, and I can totally get off the hook for all this money that I owe. I'm just going to keep on hitting it, boom, boom, boom, boom.
他在玩弄这个系统。就像说，天哪，有这个魔法按钮，我可以完全不用还我欠的那些钱。我只要不停地按它，砰，砰，砰，砰。
Oh, you see, now you're confusing me. Because, up until now, I thought the magic button was a really good thing, and now I think maybe it's a bad thing too.
哦，你看，现在你把我搞糊涂了。因为在此之前，我还以为这魔法按钮是个好东西，现在我觉得它可能也是个坏东西。
Well, what it is-- it could be a good thing or a bad thing. I felt conflicted about it. It seems strange that you wouldn't now have to pay off anything of what you borrowed.
嗯，它是好是坏，取决于你怎么看。我对此感到矛盾。如果借了钱却不需要偿还，这确实很奇怪。
Well, today, on our program, magic words. They can be used for good or for evil. We have stories of magic words that supposedly do all kinds of incredible things, like erase your debts, as you just heard, or make you rich, levitate you, help you get along better with your older relatives whose minds are going. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, with the same magic words that I intone every week at this time, full of hope that they're going to work, even though the actual magic they contain is next to nothing. Those words, stay with us.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们要聊聊“魔法咒语”。它们可以用于善，也可以用于恶。我们有一些关于魔法咒语的故事，据说它们能创造各种奇迹，比如像你刚才听到的那样免除债务，或者让你变富有、让你悬浮、帮助你与渐渐糊涂的长辈更好地相处。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），用我每周此时都会念出的同样的魔法咒语，怀着希望它们会奏效的心情，尽管它们所包含的真正魔力几乎为零。这些话，请留下来。
Act One, I believe I can fly. So there's this book full of magic words that one of our contributors, Jonathan Goldstein, found in his apartment when he was moving. He hadn't looked at it in over 30 years. It's called Ultra-Psychonics-- How to Work Miracles with the Limitless Power of Psychoatomic Energy. It was written by a man named Walter Delaney, published in 1975. And the book's premise, its basic premise, is that just as objects are composed of atoms, thoughts are composed of psychic atoms, or Delaney calls psychons, ultrons, and egons. And I'm just going to let Jonathan explain what all that means.
第一幕：我相信我能飞。有一本写满魔法咒语的书，是我们撰稿人乔纳森·戈尔茨坦（Jonathan Goldstein）搬家时在公寓里发现的。他已经三十多年没看过它了。书名是《超心理学——如何用无限的心理原子能创造奇迹》。由沃尔特·德莱尼（Walter Delaney）撰写，出版于1975年。这本书的前提，其基本前提是，正如物体由原子组成，思想也由心理原子组成，或者德莱尼称之为心理子（psychons）、超原子（ultrons）和自我原子（egons）。我将让乔纳森来解释这一切意味着什么。
I was 11 years old when my father walked into my bedroom and handed me a copy of Ultra-Psychonics. He wasn't much of a gift-giver, more of a check-giver, but I was into magic tricks and fantasy novels. So when he saw it in a used book store, he must have thought it would be right up my alley.
我11岁那年，父亲走进卧室递给我一本《超心理学》。他不是个喜欢送礼的人，更多是给钱，但我当时喜欢魔术和奇幻小说。所以当他在二手书店看到这本书时，一定觉得正合我意。
The frayed yellow dust jacket promised a grab bag of every occult slash psychology slash self-help topic under the sun, all in 237 pages. Among other things, the book promised to teach you how to shoot mental laser beams, move solid objects with your mind, make others obey your command, multiply your brain power by a factor of 1,000, and defend yourself against demonic attack.
泛黄且磨损的书封承诺它是一本囊括了所有神秘学、心理学、自助话题的万宝囊，全书共237页。除其他外，书里承诺教你如何发射心理激光束、用意念移动固体、让别人服从你的命令、将你的脑力提高1000倍，并保护自己免受恶魔攻击。
Ultra-Psychonics revealed what I always suspected-- that the adult world operated on magic. Finding a job, a wife, acquiring a bag of Egg McMuffins with a mere flash of a plastic card, how else were these things accomplished? To an 11-year-old, the book's theory seemed as plausible as anything else. An excerpt from page 217 explains the secret of ultra levitation.
《超心理学》揭示了我一直以来的怀疑——成年人的世界靠魔法运行。找工作、找老婆、仅凭刷一下塑料卡就买到一袋麦当劳满福堡，这些事情还能是怎么完成的？对于一个11岁的孩子来说，书里的理论看起来和其他任何东西一样可信。第217页的一段摘录解释了“超悬浮”的秘密。
"One, remove all your clothes and stand on a bathroom scale. Two, generate the ultronic power globe on a string, as you did for the ultronic poltergeist technique. Three, concentrate on making it rise like a balloon, lifting you with it. Four, keep your eyes on the scale. It will start to drop bit by bit, showing that you are getting lighter."
“第一步，脱光衣服站在体重秤上。第二步，生成像你做超心理骚灵技术时那样悬挂在绳子上的超心理能量球。第三步，集中注意力让它像气球一样升起，带着你一起上升。第四步，盯着体重秤看。它会一点一点下降，显示你正在变轻。”
This wasn't your granddaddy's old levitation. This was ultra levitation. And most importantly for me, Ultra-Psychonics required neither time nor effort. The inside flap stated it was as simple, easy, and natural as breathing. And for a child adept at breathing, but little else, this was exciting news.
这不是你爷爷辈那种老掉牙的悬浮术。这是超悬浮。最重要的是，对我来说，《超心理学》既不需要时间也不需要努力。内封上写着它像呼吸一样简单、容易且自然。对于一个除了呼吸什么都不会的孩子来说，这真是个令人激动的消息。
In those dark ignorant days before the universal remote, one had to rise, not unlike an animal, from one's perch to change TV stations. By using ultra kinetics, as outlined in chapter 13, I'd never have to debase myself that way again. Never again would I have to suffer through the depressing stage lighting of Barney Miller when the Beverly Hillbillies was a mere psychic click away. No longer would I be pathetic. I would be ultra telepathetic.
在那个没有万能遥控器的黑暗无知年代，人们必须像动物一样从座位上起身去换台。通过利用第13章概述的“超动力学”，我再也不用以那种方式贬低自己了。再也不用在《Beverly Hillbillies》只在心理距离轻轻一按就能播放时，忍受《Barney Miller》那令人沮丧的舞台灯光。我不再可悲，我将拥有超感知力。
This was during the Eden of my pre-adolescence, a time when I had yet to discover the K-Mart lingerie insert, and so had plenty of time on my hands. I wasted hours in bed, lying flat on my stomach, with the book open at my side, squinting so hard that my vision began to blur as I tried to close the bedroom door with my mind. Even though I had, as the book instructed, dutifully turned on the ultronic generator in my head to stimulate my flow of ultrons, I was getting nowhere.
那是我青春期前的伊甸园时期，那时我还没发现凯马特（K-Mart）的内衣插页，所以有大把的时间。我浪费了几个小时躺在床上，平趴着，书摊在身边，眯着眼试图用意念关上卧室门，眼睛眯到视线都开始模糊了。尽管我按照书的指示，勤奋地打开了大脑里的超感发电机来刺激我的超原子流动，但我一无所获。
I assumed the fault was mine, that I was not following the instructions properly. But reading it now, it's hard to figure out how anyone could follow along. I now wonder whether my father knew it was insane, and had only gifted me with the book as a means of getting me out of his hair. He could read in peace, while his son stared at a doorjamb for hours on end. I wonder if my father still even remembered the book.
我以为是我的错，是我没按说明操作。但现在读起来，很难想象有人能照着做。我现在怀疑我父亲是否知道它很疯狂，只是为了不让他心烦才送我这本书的。他可以安静地读书，而他的儿子正盯着门框看上几个小时。我怀疑我父亲是否还记得这本书。
Yes.
记得。
You remember it?
你记得？
Yes.
记得。
Right off the bat?
一下子就想起来了？
Right.
对。
I thought I'd have to refresh your memory.
我以为还得提醒你一下。
No, no, no. I remember it well. It's all kinds of psycho-- what do you call it? Experiments and magic, very scientifically proven, and concrete, and so forth. They give you a formula, step-by-step way of doing it, et cetera.
不用，不用。我记得很清楚。那是各种心理——你管它叫什么？实验和魔法，非常科学证明的，具体的，诸如此类的东西。他们给你一个公式，一步步去做的方法，等等。
Did you try any of the techniques that were offered in the book?
你试过书里提供的任何技巧吗？
No, I never tried any of the-- but, for some reason, I thought maybe there's a certain amount of validity, maybe.
不，我从来没试过任何——但出于某种原因，我当时想，也许它确实有一定道理。
But I don't know that I necessarily think of you as a believer in that kind of stuff.
但我不知道我是否必然认为你是一个相信这类东西的人。
I pooh-pooh it. I don't pooh-pooh anything.
我向来嗤之以鼻。我什么都不嗤之以鼻。
This is patently false. My father has pooh-poohed everything, from sushi to liquid soap. He's pooh-poohed abstract expressionism, the Rolling Stones, and the entire state of Florida. He once even pooh-poohed my Pu Pu platter, telling me egg rolls were best enjoyed cold. In fact, whenever my great uncle Saul bragged about how his other nephew, Barney, was a successful doctor, my father pooh-poohed the hell out of that. Getting himself worked up, he'd insist that a chiropodist was no doctor.
这话显然不对。我父亲对一切都嗤之以鼻，从寿司到洗手液。他嘲笑抽象表现主义、滚石乐队，甚至是整个佛罗里达州。有一次他甚至嘲笑我的“普普盘”（Pu Pu platter），告诉我蛋卷最好冷着吃。事实上，每当我大伯索尔吹嘘他的另一个侄子巴尼是一位成功的医生时，我父亲都嗤之以鼻。他会激动起来，坚持说足科医生算不上医生。
You remember mom's uncle Saul used to have a nephew named Barney?
你记得妈的大伯索尔有个叫巴尼的侄子吗？
A chiropodist.
那个足科医生。
A foot doctor.
那个脚医生。
No, he's not medical doctor, no. You're not an M.D. Can't operate on my foot.
不，他不是医学博士，不。你不是医学博士。没法给我做手术。
Here's what I'm saying is I--
我想说的是我——
If I have a bunion or a corn.
如果我长了拇囊炎或鸡眼。
I bring that up to illustrate the fact that you don't just swallow things hook, line, and sinker. Here was somebody presenting someone as a foot doctor and you said, no, he's not a doctor.
我提这个是为了说明你不只是不加思索地全盘接受东西。有人介绍一个人是脚医生，你说，不，他不是医生。
That's right.
没错。
So, but, I mean, in the case of this, I imagine, you approached it probably with some skepticism.
所以，但在这种情况下，我想，你大概是抱着怀疑态度接触它的。
This book, it was kind of-- how could I put it-- seemed to me to be backed by some fact.
这本书，它有点——我该怎么说——在我看来是有一些事实支持的。
Why?
为什么？
The way it was written.
它书写的风格。
What was it about the way that it was written?
它的书写风格有什么特别的？
Well, the way-- because it was so concrete, so specific. There was nothing vague about it. It's a sold book. It's got a table of contents, if I remember. It's not like any little leaflet or a pamphlet.
好吧，它的书写方式——因为它太具体了，太详细了。没有一点模棱两可的地方。它是本实实在在的书。如果我没记错的话，它有目录。不像什么传单或小册子。
Whoever wrote this, well, he put a lot of effort into it. I'll tell you that. He put a lot of effort into it. I get the feeling this guy wasn't trying to con anybody. He really believed what he was writing.
不管是谁写的，嗯，他花了很多心血。我告诉你，他花了很多心血。我有种感觉，这家伙不是在诈骗谁。他真的相信他写的内容。
Did Walter Delaney really believe what he was writing? Believe, for instance, that while the old-fashioned zodiac was outdated, his psychonic zodiac, with its cryanox, vernox, estavox, and invernox signs was more scientific as it was seasonally based? And that even if you were born under the estavox summer sign, you might exhibit a more cryanox winter type personality if you were born in an air conditioned hospital?
沃尔特·德莱尼真的相信他写的东西吗？比如相信旧式的黄道十二宫已经过时，而他的心理黄道十二宫，带有 cryanox、vernox、estavox 和 invernox 标志，因为是基于季节的，所以更科学？甚至即便你出生在 estavox 夏季标志下，如果你出生在有空调的医院里，你也可能表现出更像 cryanox 冬季类型的人格？
The back of the book refers to him as, quote, "one of the world's leading authorities on the psychic and occult sciences." But I could find no mention of him anywhere on the internet. It was only when I searched on Walter Delaney and pseudonym that I finally got a lead. It turns out that, like so many other mystical men from Leonard Susskind to Regis Philbin to my father, Buzz Goldstein, Walter Delaney was originally a Jew from the Bronx by the name of Joseph Schaumberger.
书的背面称他为，引述：“世界领先的心理学和神秘科学权威之一。”但我在互联网上找不到任何关于他的提及。直到我搜索“沃尔特·德莱尼”和“笔名”时，我才终于有了头绪。事实证明，像莱昂纳德·萨斯坎德（Leonard Susskind）、瑞吉斯·菲尔宾（Regis Philbin）以及我父亲巴兹·戈尔茨坦（Buzz Goldstein）等许多神秘男士一样，沃尔特·德莱尼最初是个来自布朗克斯的犹太人，名叫约瑟夫·绍姆伯格（Joseph Schaumberger）。
Schaumberger passed away in 2011, but I managed to track down his daughter, Barbara. She was in her early 20s when her dad was writing the book, and she remembers it clearly. At the time, Schaumberger was living in New Jersey and making a decent wage as an editor at a publishing house that specialized in occult self-help books with titles like Secrets from Beyond the Pyramids and The Magic of Chantomatics . And he was astonished by the amount of money he saw writers making. Here's Barbara.
绍姆伯格于2011年去世，但我还是找到了他的女儿芭芭拉。她父亲写这本书时她才20出头，她记忆犹新。当时，绍姆伯格住在新泽西州，在一家出版社当编辑，那家出版社专门出版神秘自助书籍，书名如《金字塔背后的秘密》和《咒语魔法》。他对自己看到的作家赚取的巨额财富感到惊讶。这是芭芭拉。
They were just taking buckets of money home and it was driving him crazy. So his wife, Dorothy, said, well, why don't you write one of these books yourself?
他们只是把一桶桶的钱带回家，这让他快疯了。所以他妻子桃乐丝说，好吧，你怎么不自己写一本这种书呢？
Had he ever written a book before?
他以前写过书吗？
No. What he did was he did this careful study. He just flipped through magazines, and looked at newspapers, and he read scientific journals, and such. So from that combination of things, he just pulled ideas out and made what sounded good to him.
没有。他所做的就是进行仔细研究。他翻阅杂志、查看报纸、阅读科学期刊之类。所以通过这些东西的组合，他只是拼凑出了一些想法，写出了让他听起来觉得不错的内容。
Was his intention to make it scientific or was it--
他的意图是让它科学化还是——
No. No, his intention was to make money. You have to understand that this was just a-- it started out as a kind of warped family joke. And he'd read it to the family and say, does this sound reasonable? Does this sound interesting?
不，不。他的意图是赚钱。你得明白这只是一个——起初这是一种扭曲的家庭笑话。他会读给家人听，然后说，这听起来合理吗？这听起来有趣吗？
Do you remember him reading you actual passages from the book?
你记得他读过书里的实际段落吗？
Oh, yeah. The best one, our family-- the absolute family favorite was the money one, where he-- one chapter was about money, about making money.
哦，是的。最棒的那个，我们全家——全家最喜欢的绝对是关于钱的那一个，他——其中有一章是关于钱的，关于如何赚钱。
I think that was in the chapter on ultra pictronics, how to materialize the riches you desire.
我想那是在关于“超心理学”那一章，如何实现你渴望的财富。
I'll be honest, I've never read the whole book all the way through. But, anyway, he said this is where you would go around the house and you would gather up your bills, and your bank statements, and your wallet, and such, and you'd put them all under your pillow. And then you would have this formula, this chant that you would use.
说实话，我从来没从头到尾读完这本书。但无论如何，他说这是你需要在家四处走动，收集你的账单、银行对账单、钱包之类，把它们全都放在枕头底下。然后你就会有这样一个公式，这个你会用的咒语。
The lyrics go, "My money lies under my pillow, my money lies close to me. No matter what I do tomorrow, bring back my money to me." This was written to be sung to the tune of "My Bonnie Lies Over The Ocean." Any time I hear those words, I can hear it in my head. I can hear the echo of my father singing that song.
歌词是，“我的钱躺在枕头下，我的钱离我很近。无论明天我做什么，把我的钱还给我。”这是写给“My Bonnie Lies Over The Ocean”这首歌的调子。每次我听到这些话，我都能在脑海里听到。我能听到我父亲唱这首歌的回音。
Looking at it now, it seems obvious it was a lark. It almost reads like a parody of another famous science fictiony slash self-helpy book with a lot of pseudo science jargon, that, for legal reasons, I will only say rhymes with diuretics. Take, for instance, the astral spur.
现在看起来，很明显这就是个恶作剧。它读起来几乎像是另一本著名的科幻兼自助书的戏仿，里面有很多伪科学行话，由于法律原因，我只会说它和“利尿剂”押韵。以“星体马刺”为例。
You were supposed to use it at the racetrack to give your horse extra energy. And it involved standing on one foot and projecting a psychic laser at your horse's hindquarters. And then there's the section on ultra vision influence. The road to domination is explained this way.
你本应在赛马场上使用它，给你的马增加额外的能量。它涉及单脚站立，并向你马的后胯投射一个心理激光。还有关于“超视觉影响”的一节。统治之路是这样解释的。
"One, sit in front of a mirror and practice staring fixedly into your own eyes. Two, practice the look on animals. Cats are the best. See if you can stare down a cat. Don't be surprised if the cat seems to win the first few rounds. Three, practice the look on strangers on various forms of public transport. Stare steadily at someone sitting opposite you until you force them to turn their head away or look down. You have just mastered your first human subject."
“第一步，坐在镜子前练习盯着自己的眼睛看。第二步，对着动物练习这种眼神。猫是最好的。看看你能不能盯着猫看，直到它挪开眼。如果猫看起来赢了前几轮，不要感到惊讶。第三步，对着公共交通工具上的陌生人练习。坚定地盯着坐在你对面的人，直到你强迫他们转过头或低下头。你就掌握了你的第一个人类课题。”
I'm not that surprised, but I'm a little saddened or the part of me-- because I discovered the book when I was like 11 years old. So that little kid part of me--
我并不惊讶，但我有一点难过，或者说是我的那一部分——因为我在11岁左右的时候发现了这本书。所以那个孩子气的一部分我——
Oh, I'm so sorry.
哦，我很抱歉。
No, no. It makes sense. Because there are parts in the book where he references things like the Tibetan Book of the Dead and the golden flower and things from eastern philosophy.
不，不。这说得通。因为书里有些地方他引用了像《西藏度亡经》和《金花》之类的东西，以及来自东方哲学的东西。
Oh, he was very familiar with all these things. Like the Egyptian Book of the Dead was a big one, because it was always the thing of, well, maybe if they had followed the formulas correctly, maybe something--
哦，他非常熟悉所有这些东西。就像《埃及度亡经》是一个大部头，因为总是那句话，好吧，也许如果他们正确地遵循了公式，也许会发生点什么——
He would say that?
他会那样说？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
That sounds like someone who either did believe or kind of wanted to believe.
那听起来像是一个要么相信，要么有点想相信的人。
He may have wanted to believe. It may be that, in his private thoughts, there were some things in there that he believed in. He wouldn't have-- I can't see him as sharing that with us because he didn't want to open himself up to ridicule. No, he was your-- he was a very geeky science fiction fan looking person. The thick, black, and heavy-lensed eye glasses, kind of a short, pudgy, Jewish boy from the Bronx. No, he was a very quiet, private person.
他可能想相信。也许在内心的思考中，有一些东西是他相信的。他不会——我看不出他会与我们分享，因为他不想让自己遭到嘲笑。不，他是你的——他是一个非常极客的科幻迷形象。厚重、黑色、镜片很厚的眼镜，一个来自布朗克斯的矮胖、犹太小男孩。不，他是一个非常安静、私密的人。
Do you have any idea how he arrived upon the name Walter Delaney?
你知道他是怎么想到“沃尔特·德莱尼”这个名字的吗？
Oh, of course. He was at the office and the book was all ready for publication, going through all the copy editing. And he wandered into the men's room at Prentice Hall, and thinking where am I going to find a name. What name can I use that's not going to be identifiable? And he just kind of looked at the top of the urinal and there was the brand of the urinal, Delany Flushboy. So it became Walter Delaney from the Delany Flushboy urinal.
哦，当然。他在办公室，书已经准备好出版了，正在进行编辑校对。他溜进普伦蒂斯霍尔（Prentice Hall）的男洗手间，在想我该去哪找个名字呢。我可以用什么不会被识别出来的名字？他只是随意看了看小便池的顶部，那是小便池的品牌，“Delany Flushboy”。所以它就变成了从 Delany Flushboy 小便池来的“沃尔特·德莱尼”。
Barbara told me that not only did her father make enough money from the book to buy a large, beautiful house and take his wife on European vacations where they went to operas, she also said that Schaumberger received boxes and boxes of letters from readers thanking him and requesting further guidance.
芭芭拉告诉我，她父亲不仅靠这本书赚够了钱买了一座漂亮的大房子，还带妻子去欧洲度假看歌剧，她还说绍姆伯格收到了成箱成箱读者的来信，感谢他并请求进一步指导。
In rereading the book all these years later, I still remembered the stuff about how to travel to the furthest reaches of the galaxy through mind power. But what I didn't remember at all was the last chapter, chapter 14. In the book's introduction, Schaumberger promises that in the final chapter he would reveal nothing short of the meaning of life. What could be of less interest to an 11-year-old?
多年后重读这本书，我还记得关于如何用意念力到达星系最远端的内容。但我完全不记得最后一章，第14章。在书的序言中，绍姆伯格承诺在最后一章中他将揭示人生的意义。对于一个11岁的孩子来说，还有什么比这更没兴趣的吗？
And what does the chapter contain? It outlines the 10 actions for leading a good life-- the joy of giving, humility, working, caring, fidelity, sufficiency, calmness, learning, meditation, and reverence. Nothing flashy, no ultras, just the golden rule kind of stuff.
那一章包含什么内容？它概述了引导美好生活的10个行动——给予的快乐、谦逊、工作、关怀、忠诚、知足、冷静、学习、冥想和崇敬。没有浮夸，没有超能力，只有金科玉律之类的内容。
I asked Barbara why she thought her father included all this straightforward do unto others kind of thing with nigh a single ultra in sight.
我问芭芭拉为什么她认为她父亲要把所有这些直截了当的“己所不欲，勿施于人”之类的东西放进去，而且几乎没提任何超能力。
I think he believed in that quite passionately, and that would have been the only platform he had. And if there was anything that would transform their lives, it wasn't going to be gained by chanting. It would be gained by living your life according to some basic principles of decency.
我想他非常热切地相信这一点，而这可能是他拥有的唯一平台。如果有什么能改变他们的生活，那不会是通过念咒获得的。那将通过根据一些基本的体面原则生活来获得。
"Chapter 14 is the last stage in Ultra-Psychonics," wrote Schaumberger. "It is the culmination of many long and arduous years of research. Please do not try to read it now. You will not be able to understand it until you have mastered the rest of the book. But once you are ready for it, I think you will find it to be one of the most profound and rewarding experiences in your life."
“第14章是《超心理学》的最后阶段，”绍姆伯格写道，“这是多年艰苦研究的结晶。请不要现在试着去读它。在掌握书的其他内容之前，你无法理解它。但一旦你准备好了，我想你会发现它将是你一生中最深刻、最有意义的经历之一。”
Of all the chapters in Schaumberger's book, it's this last one that might be the hardest of all to master. It's the chapter with the fewest instructions. And, on some days, I still don't feel quite ready for it.
在绍姆伯格书中的所有章节里，这最后一章可能是最难掌握的。它是指导最少的一章。而且，有些日子，我仍然觉得没完全准备好。
Jonathan Goldstein is the author of a number of books, including Ladies and Gentlemen, the Bible. Coming up, how to properly use monkeys-- yes, monkeys, I said monkeys-- for the betterment of your family. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦著有多本书，包括《女士们先生们，圣经》。接下来，如何恰当地利用猴子——是的，猴子，我说猴子——来改善你的家庭。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, magic words. They're used for good, they're used for evil. We wish that they're going to work. We cross our fingers and we wait to see if they will work. We've arrived at act two of our program.
《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，并带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，魔法咒语。它们被用于善，它们被用于恶。我们希望它们能奏效。我们交叉手指，等待看看它们是否会奏效。我们进入了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Rainy days and Mondays. According to the Alzheimer's Association, every 67 seconds, somebody in the United States develops the disease. We're at this point with Alzheimer's where almost everybody has had some sort of personal experience with the disease, through a spouse or a parent or a friend. And because we've had that direct experience, we all know how scary Alzheimer's can be.
第二幕，下雨天和星期一。根据阿尔茨海默病协会的说法，在美国，每67秒就有人患上这种病。我们正处于阿尔茨海默病的这个阶段，几乎每个人都通过配偶、父母或朋友对这种病有某种个人经历。正因为我们有那种直接的体验，我们都知道阿尔茨海默病有多可怕。
The thing you hear a lot is the emotional toll of taking care of parents and spouses. And you hear about the cost. But there is this other, more basic challenge. People don't talk about this as much, but it must be a problem that everyone close to the disease struggles with. And that is what are we supposed to talk about with our relatives who have Alzheimer's. What do we talk about? The same stuff we always have?
你常听到的是照顾父母和配偶的情感代价。你也听到相关的费用。但还有另一个更基本的挑战。人们谈论这个并不多，但它肯定是每个与疾病密切相关的人都在挣扎的问题。那就是我们应该和患有阿尔茨海默病的亲人谈论什么。我们谈什么？谈我们一直谈的那些东西？
Did they tell you Jenny and Joe are moving to Florida?
他们告诉你珍妮和乔要搬到佛罗里达了吗？
No.
没有。
Joe got a promotion and they're going to go to Florida.
乔升职了，他们要去佛罗里达。
Sharon Stobbe is sitting on the back porch of her sister's home with her mom, Virginia.
莎伦·斯托贝（Sharon Stobbe）和母亲弗吉尼亚（Virginia）坐在她姐姐家的后门廊上。
You were in Florida.
你去过佛罗里达。
Sharon says to her mom, you were in Florida.
莎伦对她妈妈说，你去过佛罗里达。
Where were you?
你去哪儿了？
Let me think. I can't remember.
让我想想。我不记得了。
Do you remember who you were with?
你记得你和谁在一起吗？
This is a little off mic. She says, do you remember who you were with.
这有点偏离麦克风了。她说，你记得你和谁在一起吗。
I was with Betty. Oh, dear.
我和贝蒂在一起。噢，亲爱的。
And you met somebody there.
你在那里遇见了某个人。
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
星期一、星期二、星期三、星期四、星期五。
You met somebody special there.
你在那里遇见了一个特别的人。
Dad. Dad is the answer Sharon's searching for. My father, your husband. Sharon didn't go into this conversation trying to play some memory game with her mom. She just kind of fell into that. And it's easy to see how, right?
爸爸。爸爸是莎伦在找的答案。我父亲，你丈夫。莎伦并不是带着和她妈妈玩记忆游戏的目的去进行这段对话的。她只是碰巧陷入了那种境地。这很容易理解，对吧？
You love your mom, you want to spend time with your mom. What are you going to talk about? Shared memories are out, mutual loved ones are not remembered. Even current news, like joyful news, does not necessarily create a connection. Right before they sat down on the porch, Sharon's sister showed Virginia a picture of her two-week-old granddaughter, said, Mom, look how beautiful your great-granddaughter-- and Virginia looked at the picture and said, oh, no, for no clear reason at all.
你爱你的妈妈，你想花时间陪她。你会谈论什么？共同的记忆已经不存在了，共同爱的人也不记得了。即使是当前的新闻，比如快乐的新闻，也不一定会建立联系。就在他们坐在门廊上之前，莎伦的姐姐给弗吉尼亚看了她两周大的孙女的照片，说，妈，看看你的曾孙女多漂亮——弗吉尼亚看着照片说，哦，不，毫无理由地。
Sharon has a sister named Karen. And Sharon's the oldest, Karen's the youngest. Virginia, the mom, was with Karen. And one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, got interested in this experiment that Karen has been trying in their family. Karen's been on a search for a new way to talk to her mom, looking for some magic words to say to her mom as her mom is losing her memory, words that will keep them connected.
莎伦有个姐妹叫凯伦。莎伦是老大，凯伦是最小的。弗吉尼亚，那个妈妈，当时和凯伦在一起。我们的制作人之一，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt），对凯伦一直在家庭中尝试的这个实验产生了兴趣。凯伦一直在寻找一种与她妈妈交流的新方法，在寻找一些魔法咒语说给渐渐失去记忆的妈妈听，这些词能让他们保持联系。
And, recently, she developed a plan, a fully formed theory of social interaction for the dementia landscape. She's got rules, she's got best practices. It's a whole thing. And she thinks it can work. Here's Chana Joffe-Walt to explain.
而且，最近，她制定了一个计划，一套完整的关于痴呆症背景下的社会互动理论。她有规则，有最佳实践。这整套东西。她认为它能奏效。这是查娜·乔夫-沃尔特来解释。
Karen didn't have the plan in place when her mom first moved in with her, but she has wanted a plan from day one. Day one, there was just this constant stream of questions that never had definitive answers, like can I leave my mom at home alone, or what am I supposed to do when she wakes up at 2:00 in the morning and starts getting dressed? What about when she wants another bowl of ice cream? And I remind her that she has diabetes, but she forgets that she has diabetes.
当她妈妈第一次搬进来时，凯伦还没制定好计划，但她从第一天起就想要个计划。第一天，只是一连串永远没有明确答案的问题，比如我可以把妈妈一个人留在家里吗，或者当她在凌晨2点醒来开始穿衣服时我该怎么办？当她想要另一碗冰淇淋时怎么办？我提醒她有糖尿病，但她忘了自己有糖尿病。
See, Karen is a person who likes structure. The lawless do-it-yourself nature of home dementia care never sat well with her. Karen would do what she thought was right, take the ice cream away, and her mom would lose it, scream at her. This is a woman who never had a cruel word to say about anyone, who considered shoot a swear word. She would look right into Karen's eyes and say you're a supreme [BLEEP], you know that?
你看，凯伦是个喜欢条理的人。家庭痴呆症护理中这种无法无天的“自己动手”性质从来不适合她。凯伦会做她认为正确的事，把冰淇淋拿走，她妈妈就会失控，对她尖叫。这是一个从未对任何人说过一句恶毒的话，甚至认为“该死”都是脏话的女人。她会直视凯伦的眼睛说，你是个彻头彻尾的[哔]，你知道吗？
I had this moment where I Googled the rules of caregiving for someone with Alzheimer's. And I thought-- I wondered, for some reason, if they were even out there, if there was some. And when I read one of them that said, literally, step into their world, I went, bam.
我有一次谷歌搜索了阿尔茨海默病患者的护理规则。我当时想——出于某种原因，我想知道它们是否存在，是否有一些。当我读到其中一条说，字面上写着“走进他们的世界”，我当时就想，砰。
Step into their world was a familiar phrase to Karen from the many nights she had spent doing improv comedy. She and her husband are actors. Step into their world is a mantra in improv. You walk on stage, another actor says something, and you step into their world, whatever world they have just created.
对于在即兴喜剧中度过许多夜晚的凯伦来说，“走进他们的世界”是一个熟悉的短语。她和丈夫都是演员。走进他们的世界是即兴表演中的一句口头禅。你走上舞台，另一个演员说了什么，你就走进他们的世界，无论他们刚刚创造了什么世界。
You don't ever say no, you don't question their premise. You just say yes. And--
你从来不说不，你不会质疑他们的前提。你只是说“是的，而且”。
I didn't even see it. I didn't see the whole parallels of improv and Alzheimer's. And when I did, it was-- it was just so obvious. It's a whole "yes, and" world.
我甚至没看到这一点。我没看到即兴表演和阿尔茨海默病之间的全部平行之处。当我看到时，它——它太明显了。这是一个完整的“是的，而且”的世界。
If all you've got is "yes, and," you can't say things like, but you don't even like pickles, or you don't have a sister, Mom. You don't tell someone they're wrong, which Karen says is exactly what you always want to do. Like when her mom says she wants to go home, the most natural response is--
如果你只有“是的，而且”，你就不能说诸如“但你根本不喜欢泡菜”或者“你没姐妹，妈”之类的话。你不能告诉别人他们错了，凯伦说这正是你一直想做的。比如当她妈妈说想回家时，最自然的反应是——
Oh, but this is your home now, Virginia. Come, let me show you me your room. But this woman is looking at you, saying, I want to go home, and you're telling her she lives here. So, now, you're telling her she's a liar, so you're going to see her little veins start popping out in her neck and her little fists.
哦，但这是你现在的家，弗吉尼亚。来，让我带你看看你的房间。但这个女人看着你，说，我想回家，而你却告诉她她住这儿。所以，现在，你在说她是骗子，所以你会看到她脖子上的小静脉开始凸起，还有她的小拳头。
But if you look at her and you say-- she says I want to go home. Yes, and tell me about your home.
但如果你看着她说——她说“我想回家”。是的，而且告诉我关于你的家。
Now, she's not a liar anymore. Karen felt like she had discovered an instruction manual. Here was a way into a relationship with her mom if she just followed some basic rules of engagement, rules she conveniently already knew. And so did her husband, Mondy, who was glad to have some guidelines for how to relate to this new roommate. It's like improv, Karen explained. You love improv.
现在，她不再是骗子了。凯伦觉得自己发现了一本说明书。如果她遵循一些基本的互动规则，如果她遵循一些她方便已经知道的规则，这就是进入与她妈妈关系的一种方式。她的丈夫蒙迪（Mondy）也一样，他很高兴有一些关于如何与这位新室友相处的指导方针。就像即兴表演，凯伦解释道。你爱即兴表演。
That's when I was like, OK, that's cool. I know how to do that, and that's what I'll do.
那时我就像，好的，这很酷。我知道怎么做，我就会这样做。
For Karen, using the tools of improv meant when her mom, Virginia, sees monkeys out the window, don't correct her. But Mondy-- Mondy took the whole thing to the next level. When Virginia sees monkeys, Mondy sees them too. He told me, oh, yeah, just the last time that happened, I said--
对于凯伦来说，使用即兴表演工具意味着当她妈妈弗吉尼亚看到窗外有猴子时，不要纠正她。但蒙迪——蒙迪把整件事提升到了一个新的水平。当弗吉尼亚看到猴子时，蒙迪也看到了。他告诉我，哦，是的，就在上次发生这种情况时，我说——
It's pretty early in the season for monkeys. Didn't even know actually that they were here in North Carolina. Oh, there's not a lot of them, but they're pretty busy now. Well, if you see one again, we should try and capture it because that would be a blast to have in the house. You can't keep monkeys in the house. Well, we could-- you just have to train them right and give them pants, because if they don't have pants-- I mean, it's-- that's just a barbarian's monkey.
现在季节还很早，不该有猴子。甚至不知道它们竟然在北卡罗来纳州。哦，没多少，但它们现在很忙。好吧，如果你再看到一只，我们应该试着抓住它，因为把它养在屋里会很有趣。你不能把猴子养在屋里。好吧，我们可以——你只需要好好训练它们，给它们穿上裤子，因为如果它们没穿裤子——我是说，那——那只是野蛮人的猴子。
We can't have monkeys in the house. All right, all right, so I guess you're making up a rule that we can't have monkeys in the house. Yes, I am, but she would-- at some point, there's something in her mind that's going we're not being serious now about monkeys in the house.
我们不能把猴子养在屋里。好了，好了，所以我猜你在编造一个我们不能把猴子养在屋里的规则。是的，我是，但她会——在某个时候，她脑子里有东西在说，我们现在不是在认真对待屋里的猴子。
And it's fun for her?
这对她来说有趣吗？
And it's fun for her, yeah. Yeah, she's definitely having a good time.
这对她来说很有趣，是的。是的，她肯定玩得很开心。
For years, the staff in nursing homes and dementia care experts advised families to keep your loved ones with you, mentally speaking. Remind them who they are, where they're from, show them pictures of your family. Hang orientation boards everywhere that say today is August 15, the weather is overcast, the president is Barack Obama.
多年来，疗养院的工作人员和痴呆症护理专家建议家庭成员把你所爱的人和你保持一致，从心理层面讲。提醒他们是谁，来自哪里，给他们看你们家庭的照片。到处挂上定向板，上面写着今天是8月15日，天气阴天，总统是巴拉克·奥巴马。
But recently, the experts have changed course. And in the last decade or so, things like validation therapy are what's in. Caregivers are encouraged to listen, respond, try to live in their reality instead of trying to pull them over into yours. Basically, exactly what Karen and Mondy stumbled into on their own.
但最近，专家们改变了方针。在过去十年左右的时间里，像“验证疗法”这样的东西很流行。护理人员被鼓励倾听、回应，尝试活在他们的现实中，而不是试图把他们拉进你的世界。基本上，正是凯伦和蒙迪自己无意中发现的。
Most people find it pretty challenging to interact in this way. But for Mondy and Karen, it's not hard. Mondy does it all the time without thinking.
大多数人发现以这种方式互动很有挑战性。但对于蒙迪和凯伦来说，这并不难。蒙迪总是不用思考就能做到。
How are you doing?
你怎么样？
I'm OK.
我还好。
Yeah?
是吗？
I think.
我想。
What a day.
这一天真不错。
It's strange that when you get up the mountain, it's much lighter in the sky. I'm very-- I'm very noticeable.
很奇怪，当你上山时，天空中亮多了。我很——我非常引人注意。
You are very noticeable.
你非常引人注意。
Thanks.
谢谢。
I've noticed you--
我注意到你——
Don't--
别——
I've noticed you before.
我以前注意到你了。
Virginia points to the family terrier, Gus, tearing around the backyard, digging holes.
弗吉尼亚指着家里的梗犬盖斯（Gus），它在后院跑来跑去，挖洞。
He's digging for his life.
它正在为了生活而挖掘。
Oh, yeah, Gus is busy working on his caverns. You're starting a coal mine. So he's going to get it started, and you're going to finish it up, right?
哦，是的，盖斯正忙着挖掘它的洞穴。你正在开一家煤矿。所以它要开始挖了，你要去把它完成，对吧？
I am?
我是吗？
The coal mine?
那个煤矿？
The coal mine? I never worked in a coal mine.
那个煤矿？我从来没在煤矿工作过。
I know.
我知道。
Mondy says, but I need you to now. I need your help finishing up the mine. Gotta get out there and find some coal, so we can pay out these bills. Virginia gleefully refuses, so Mondy says, oh, well, we'll have to shut down the whole operation then.
蒙迪说，但我现在需要你帮忙。我需要你的帮助来完成这个矿井。得出去找点煤，这样我们才能付清账单。弗吉尼亚高兴地拒绝了，所以蒙迪说，哦，好吧，那我们得关闭整个行动了。
All right, Gus. No, she doesn't want to go in, man.
好了，盖斯。不，她不想进去，伙计。
Stop digging.
停止挖掘。
All right, stop digging.
好了，停止挖掘。
Stop digging.
停止挖掘。
Gus--
盖斯——
No digging. No, no, no.
不准挖掘。不，不，不。
This is a family all doing something together, sharing the same reality, the reality of closing down the coal mine in the backyard. When you're with your family, your parents or uncles, say, Thanksgiving, think about how much time you spend collectively recalling things. Remember when mom laughed so hard the juice came out of her nose? Remember when dad got in that crash? Or did I ever tell you how you potty trained yourself because you saw your brother doing it?
这是一个全家人一起做某事，分享同一个现实，即关闭后院煤矿的现实。当你和家人、父母或叔叔阿姨在一起时，比如感恩节，想想你花了多少时间集体回忆往事。记得妈妈笑得牛奶从鼻子里喷出来的时候吗？记得爸爸撞车的时候吗？或者我有没有告诉你你是怎么学会自己上厕所的，因为你看到你哥哥在做？
It's nice to share memories, makes you feel connected. But, also, usually, what you're actually doing in that moment with your family is boring. You're watching the game, eating chicken for dinner again. It's fun to recall the more dramatic moments you've shared because they are not boring, they're not boring experiences you've had together.
分享记忆很好，让你感到联系。但是，通常情况下，你和家人在一起那一刻实际上做的事很无聊。你在看球赛，晚餐又吃鸡肉。回忆你们分享过的更具戏剧性的时刻很有趣，因为它们并不无聊，不是你们一起经历过的无聊体验。
Virginia no longer has those memories to call on. She spends a lot of her day sitting on a porch, which can't be all that interesting. But when Mondy is with her, there's literally drama. They're dismantling a mine. It's the most animated and happy I see Virginia all day.
弗吉尼亚不再有那些记忆可以调用了。她一天中的大部分时间都坐在门廊上，那一定没那么有趣。但当蒙迪和她在一起时，真的会有剧情。他们在拆除一个矿井。这是我一天中看到弗吉尼亚最有活力、最快乐的时候。
Yeah. Yeah. The coal mine plan's over.
是的。是的。煤矿计划结束了。
He'll be here in a few seconds. There he is.
他几秒钟后就会到。他来了。
No more caverns.
没有更多的洞穴了。
No more Gus caverns.
没有更多的盖斯洞穴了。
Mondy and Karen moved to North Carolina from Milwaukee to live with Karen's mom. It was closer to the rest of the family. And to Mondy, it seemed like a good time to move, but he was wrong about that in one crucial way. It was 2006, right before the economy collapsed.
蒙迪和凯伦从密尔沃基搬到北卡罗来纳州和凯伦的妈妈住。这离家人的其他人更近。对于蒙迪来说，这似乎是个搬家的好时机，但在一个关键方面他错了。那是2006年，就在经济崩溃之前。
They've found other ways to make ends meet, but Mondy left behind regular acting gigs, theater contacts, teaching jobs, just assuming that he'd find that stuff in North Carolina, which didn't happen right away.
他们找到了其他维持生计的方法，但蒙迪放弃了常规的表演工作、剧院联系、教学工作，只是假设他会在北卡罗来纳州找到那些东西，但并没有马上发生。
I'm a performer. I like to-- I get on stage and I do these shows and I like an audience. And, for a long time while I was here, I didn't get a chance to perform that much, and so I guess I just kind of focused my energy towards her.
我是个表演者。我喜欢——我上台，我做这些表演，我喜欢观众。而且，当我在此时，很长一段时间里，我没机会表演太多，所以我想我只是把我的能量集中在她身上。
Towards Virginia, his mother in law. Mondy says Virginia is an excellent audience. I never have to rein myself in, I can do anything, any kind of joke. The only thing that doesn't really work is a callback. And when Virginia was with Mondy, this sweet woman everyone remembered started coming back.
朝向弗吉尼亚，他的岳母。蒙迪说弗吉尼亚是一个优秀的观众。我永远不需要克制自己，我可以做任何事，任何一种笑话。唯一不太起作用的就是“回调”。当弗吉尼亚和蒙迪在一起时，每个人记忆中那个甜美的女人开始回来了。
I'll just do like the simplest thing for her, like I'll get the cream out of the refrigerator and put in the coffee and she'll say you're the nicest person in the world. And I'll go, yes, I am the nicest person in the world. You're right. We've got to find all the people that say I'm not the nicest person and slap them in the face, and make them agree that I'm the nicest person in the world. And she'll find that pretty funny.
我只会为她做些最简单的事，比如我从冰箱里拿出奶油放进咖啡里，她就会说你是世界上最善良的人。我会说，是的，我是世界上最善良的人。你是对的。我们必须找到所有说我不是最善良的人，然后扇他们耳光，让他们承认我是世界上最善良的人。她会觉得这很有趣。
You know who doesn't find that so funny? Mondy's wife, Karen. Karen told Mondy he had to find a way to perform more, outside of the house. He was driving her crazy.
你知道谁觉得这没那么有趣吗？蒙迪的妻子凯伦。凯伦告诉蒙迪他必须找到一种在户外、在家里之外表演更多的方法。他快把她逼疯了。
Yes. Yeah. Karen's mom was fine with it, but Karen was tired of it. Their teenage daughter Grace was tired of it too. Grace is 15 years old, so when her grandmother sees something in the paper about the Beatles and says, oh, I've met them, it's like Grace is developmentally obliged to correct her. No, you didn't.
是的。是的。凯伦的妈妈对此没意见，但凯伦厌倦了。他们十几岁的女儿格蕾丝（Grace）也厌倦了。格蕾丝15岁了，所以当她奶奶在报纸上看到关于披头士乐队的事情说，哦，我见过他们，这就像格蕾丝在发育上被迫纠正她。不，你没见过。
Mondy could see where they were coming from, and he did eventually get out to more auditions, got some acting work. But, by that point, Mondy was Virginia's favorite person. Virginia regularly wakes up in the middle of the night and starts getting dressed. And it's Mondy who can get her back to bed. At breakfast, when Virginia wants another bowl of cereal, Karen will say to her, I'm sorry, Mom, your blood sugar will just go through the roof. Virginia will sometimes reply, you're always so mean to me.
蒙迪能看出她们的意思，他最终确实去参加了更多试镜，获得了一些表演工作。但到那时，蒙迪已经是弗吉尼亚最喜欢的人了。弗吉尼亚经常在半夜醒来开始穿衣服。而蒙迪能让她回到床上。早餐时，当弗吉尼亚想要另一碗麦片时，凯伦会对她说，对不起，妈，你的血糖会飙升的。弗吉尼亚有时会回答，你总是对我这么刻薄。
Karen will try, hey, could I have that bowl of cereal? No. Mom, how about something else? To which Karen's mother will occasionally reply to her daughter, I hate you.
凯伦会尝试，嘿，我能吃那碗麦片吗？不。妈，换点别的怎么样？对此，凯伦的母亲偶尔会回答她的女儿，我恨你。
But Mondy can swoop in there and go, hey, boy, that looks good. I'm so hungry. And she'd say, oh, you want this? You can have it. And I'd be like you've got to be kidding me. What the heck? What is it? What is it about him that she'll do whatever for and not me?
但蒙迪可以冲进来，嘿，伙计，那看起来不错。我好饿。她会说，哦，你想要这个吗？你可以吃了。我就想，你在开玩笑吧。什么鬼？他有什么魔力让她什么都愿意做而对我却不？
One obvious answer is Mondy's not her kid. But, remember, Karen's mom has dementia. She doesn't always know Karen is her kid. So if they're both strangers with the same approach, same words, it may just be that Mondy does it better. And that has created a bizarre reordering of the family dynamic. Karen's always been close to her mom. And, now, her mom likes Mondy more.
一个明显的答案是蒙迪不是她的孩子。但，记住，凯伦的妈妈有痴呆症。她并不总是知道凯伦是她的孩子。所以如果他们都是用同样的方法、同样的词的陌生人，可能只是蒙迪做得更好。这创造了一种奇怪的家庭动态重组。凯伦一直和她妈妈很亲近。现在，她妈妈更喜欢蒙迪。
What do you know about Mondy?
你了解蒙迪什么？
Mondy? Couldn't be a nicer fellow, very nice guy. Very kind and very nice. He's just crazy sometimes, makes you laugh.
蒙迪？再没有比他更好的伙计了，非常好的人。非常善良，非常好。他只是有时有点疯狂，让你发笑。
Virginia is sitting with Mondy on the back porch. It's the end of the day. Karen's finishing up the dishes inside. And when she's done, she wanders out back. And this is what she walks into.
弗吉尼亚正和蒙迪坐在后门廊上。一天结束了。凯伦在里面洗完碗。当她做完后，她溜到后面。这就是她走进去时看到的东西。
You're very intelligent.
你非常聪明。
I am.
我是。
Yeah, you are.
是的，你是。
That's true.
那是真的。
Very nice.
非常好。
Wonderful.
太棒了。
What else should I tell him that he is? Oh, didn't I say that-- that he's wonderful?
我还该告诉他什么他是？哦，我没说过吗——他很棒？
I don't think you said I was wonderful.
我不觉得你说我很棒。
I did. I said he was--
我说过。我说过他——
Did you say he was good looking?
你说过他长得帅吗？
Oh, he knows I know-- I mean, he is. He's handsome.
哦，他知道我知道——我的意思是，他是。他很英俊。
And he never does anything wrong?
而且他从不做错事？
No.
没有。
Because what-- what do you say sometimes? What do you say sometimes? If I say, Mondy, you forgot to take out the trash, you say, poor Mondy. Everything is poor Mondy.
因为什么——你有时说什么？你有时说什么？如果我说，蒙迪，你忘了倒垃圾，你说，可怜的蒙迪。一切都是“可怜的蒙迪”。
Just for those little things.
就为了那些小事。
Mondy could walk in and have blood all over him and say I just killed a man. Oh, poor Mondy's got blood on his shirt. That's Mom. Poor Mondy. We were keeping count at one point how many poor Mondys would happen in a day.
蒙迪可以走进来，浑身是血地说，我刚杀了一个人。哦，可怜的蒙迪衬衫上有血。那是妈妈。可怜的蒙迪。我们曾经统计过一天有多少次“可怜的蒙迪”。
Well, I like Mondy a lot.
好吧，我很喜欢蒙迪。
Grace and I were trying to get-- I was trying to get some poor Karens. I couldn't get any poor Karens.
格蕾丝和我试图——我试图得到一些“可怜的凯伦”。但我一个“可怜的凯伦”也没得到。
You expect a lot of me, you know.
你对我期望很高，你知道。
I know. I just want a little bit of poor Karen.
我知道。我只是想要一点“可怜的凯伦”。
Here is how deep Virginia's love is for Mondy. She has inserted him into her own childhood memories, the most vivid memories she still has-- swimming, riding in a fishing boat. In Virginia's telling, Mondy was there for all of it. He was there with her on the boat, swimming in the water, traveling the country. Not her husband, not Karen, Mondy. He shows up in every significant event in her life she still remembers. Like Forrest Gump, Mondy says.
这就是弗吉尼亚对蒙迪的爱有多深。她把他插入了她自己的童年记忆中，她仍然拥有的最生动的记忆——游泳、乘渔船。在弗吉尼亚的讲述中，蒙迪在那里经历了这一切。他在船上和她在一起，在水里游泳，在全国各地旅行。不是她丈夫，不是凯伦，是蒙迪。他出现在她生活中她仍然记得的每一个重大事件中。蒙迪说，就像《阿甘正传》。
Meanwhile, Virginia has completely forgotten Karen's childhood. Again, a lot of the time, she's not quite sure who Karen is. And, sometimes, she's not even sure she likes her. Like the other night, Karen was trying to get Grace to bed, and Grace was stalling.
与此同时，弗吉尼亚完全忘记了凯伦的童年。再次重申，很多时候，她不太确定凯伦是谁。有时，她甚至不确定她是否喜欢她。就像那天晚上，凯伦正试图让格蕾丝上床睡觉，而格蕾丝在拖延。
Just a few more minutes kind of thing, and I said, Grace, come on. I said, no, you need to get up-- who are you to tell her to no? And I said, well, you know, I'm her mom. No, you're not, you liar. And I was just like-- and Grace was like she is, and I was, Grace, just go-- and so, all the way up, Grace was like, that is my mom. That's my mom.
只再多几分钟，我说，格蕾丝，快点。我说，不，你需要起来——你是谁来告诉她不？我说，好吧，你知道，我是她妈妈。不，你不是，你这个骗子。我就想——格蕾丝说她是，我是，格蕾丝，快去——所以，一路走上去，格蕾丝说，那是我妈妈。那是我妈妈。
And I'm like, well, she is my daughter, and she's your granddaughter. What? No, she's not. I said, OK, and I couldn't help myself, but I said, well, who do you think she is? Well, that's mine. I said, oh, OK. Who am I? I don't know. You had nowhere to live and I took you in, so you should be thankful. Well, I am. Thank you for taking me in.
我就像，好吧，她是我的女儿，她是你的孙女。什么？不，她不是。我说，好的，我忍不住了，我说，好吧，你觉得她是谁？好吧，那是我的。我说，哦，好的。我是谁？我不知道。你无处可去，我收留了你，所以你应该心存感激。好吧，我心存感激。谢谢你收留我。
In a moment like that, the rules that Karen set up require that she deny who she is, that she is Karen, daughter of Virginia, mother of Grace, who grew up in Texas with a loving family. If Karen wants to do her plan right, she can't be that person in her own home.
在那样的时刻，凯伦设定的规则要求她否认自己的身份，即她是凯伦，弗吉尼亚的女儿，格蕾丝的妈妈，在得克萨斯州有一个充满爱的家庭中长大。如果凯伦想正确地执行她的计划，她不能在自己的家里成为那个人。
Starting each moment with a blank slate is easy for Mondy. It's fun to create a world out of nothing with this person, as he gets to know her better. But, for Karen, every interaction asks her to erase who she is.
每一个时刻都从一张白纸开始对蒙迪来说很容易。与这个人从零开始创造一个世界很有趣，因为他更加了解她。但对于凯伦来说，每一次互动都要求她抹去自己是谁。
When my mom sits there and she says, strawberries, they just make me think of home, my mind goes immediately to growing up in Texas and her and I and dad going out to this huge strawberry field and picking strawberries. And there is this piece that you just go, that you have to let that memory go.
当我妈妈坐在那里说，草莓，它们只是让我想到家，我的脑海里立即出现了在得克萨斯州长大，她和我还有爸爸出去到这个巨大的草莓地摘草莓。有一块东西你只是去，你必须放开那个记忆。
Because what you want to say is, oh, yeah, I remember. Remember we used to go to such--
因为你想说的是，哦，是的，我记得。记得我们过去常去那个——
That's not what she wants to talk about right then. And you want to go, but what about me? Because you want your own mother to have those memories about you and to talk about your experiences.
那不是她当时想谈论的。你想要去，但我呢？因为你希望你自己的母亲有关于你的那些记忆，谈论你的经历。
But Karen doesn't say the words she wants to say. She says different ones, the ones she's supposed to say.
但凯伦没说出她想说的话。她说的是别的话，那些她应该说的话。
Really, Mom? Where was it? Was it out by the cemetery?
真的吗，妈？是在哪里？是在墓地旁边吗？
Yeah, how'd you know?
是的，你怎么知道？
And you go on and listen to the story.
你就继续听那个故事。
While silently letting go of the memory that came before, letting go of the old scene, and trying to be ready for what comes next.
同时默默地放下之前的记忆，放下旧场景，试图为接下来要发生的事做好准备。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show. Karen and Mondy now offer workshops on how to use the tools of improv with people who have dementia, including a special course on how to do that if those people are your parents. Find them at in-themoment.com. That's in-themoment.com.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。凯伦和蒙迪现在提供关于如何与痴呆症患者使用即兴表演工具的讲习班，包括关于如果这些人是你的父母该如何操作的特殊课程。在 in-themoment.com 找到他们。那是 in-themoment.com。
Act Three, Pescatarian. So there's this podcast that a bunch of us here at the radio show listen to that's put out by Slate. It's hosted by Mike Pesca, who you may have heard of in the past reporting on sports for NPR. This podcast, though, is not about sports. It is about everything, about 30 minutes a day. Often about the news, though just as often not about the news.
第三幕，鱼素食者。有一个播客，我们这里电台的一群人都在听，由《Slate》杂志发布。由迈克·佩斯卡（Mike Pesca）主持，你可能过去在 NPR 听过他报道体育新闻。这个播客，虽然不是关于体育的。它是关于一切的，每天大约30分钟。通常关于新闻，尽管同样经常不是关于新闻。
I think what makes it special is just the sheer joy, the gleeful, articulate energy that Mike Pesca marshals in thinking about and dissecting the world around him. The theme today on our radio show is magic words. And I thought of Pesca today because when he is not explaining what poker can tell us about missile defense systems or filling us in on the country in Africa that is doing really, really well, Mike Pesca is somebody who seems to take great pleasure in noticing words, how people use words, and especially the misuse of words.
我想让它特别的是那种纯粹的快乐，那种轻快、清晰的能量，迈克·佩斯卡在思考和剖析他周围的世界时所展现出的能量。今天我们电台节目的主题是魔法咒语。我今天想到了佩斯卡，因为当他不在解释扑克能告诉我们关于导弹防御系统什么，或者告诉我们非洲哪个国家做得非常好时，迈克·佩斯卡似乎是一个非常乐于注意词语、人们如何使用词语，特别是词语误用的人。
For example, there was this day when Pesca heard about some new menu items at Red Lobster and he heard a phrase he simply could not let pass.
例如，有那么一天，佩斯卡听说了红龙虾餐厅（Red Lobster）的一些新菜单项目，他听到了一个他简直无法放过的短语。
So I just found out that Red Lobster has introduced lobster-topped entrees. However, I want you to listen to this commercial. About 18 seconds in, and I think you will see and hear the part where the space time crustacean continuum gets a little bent.
所以我刚刚发现红龙虾餐厅推出了龙虾顶级主菜。但是，我希望你听听这个广告。大约18秒处，我想你会看到并听到时空甲壳类连续体变得有点扭曲的地方。
How did Red Lobster makes four amazing entrees even better? With lobster. Like savory new fire-grilled shrimp topped with maritime lobster in a citrus hollandaise or the new ultimate lobster-topped lobster. Three split--
红龙虾餐厅是怎么让四道令人惊叹的主菜变得更好的？用龙虾。比如美味的新式火烤虾，上面撒着柠檬荷兰酱中的海事龙虾，或者是新的极致龙虾顶级龙虾。三个分裂——
Did you hear what the dude said? Lobster-topped lobster. Isn't that just a bigger lobster? The one thing you can't top a lobster with is another lobster. You can't top a thing with more of the thing. It's not the top, it's just the thing. Cherry on top, that makes sense. Cherry on top of a sundae.
你听见那家伙说了什么吗？龙虾顶级龙虾。那不就是一个更大的龙虾吗？你不能用另一种龙虾来顶级龙虾。你不能用同样的东西来顶级一个东西。那不是顶部，那只是那个东西。樱桃在上面，那有意义。樱桃在圣代上面。
You know what cherry on top doesn't make sense? Cherry on top of a bunch of other cherries. Just more cherries. This is why--
你知道什么在上面的樱桃没意义吗？樱桃在一堆其他樱桃上面。只是更多的樱桃。这就是为什么——
I have to say I usually hate it when people go on and on about using the right word. That is not something I usually enjoy. I don't care about that. But Pesca's delight I find totally contagious. I end up repeating what he says about this stuff to my friends and my loved ones.
我不得不说，我通常很讨厌人们一直没完没了地使用正确的词。那不是我通常享受的东西。我不关心那个。但佩斯卡的喜悦我发现完全具有传染性。我最后会把我关于这些东西的说法复述给我的朋友和亲人。
One day, he got on to the phrase, "toot your own horn." He said he'd been listening to the previous day's podcast in the interest of quality control.
有一天，他开始说“toot your own horn”（吹自己的号角，意指自吹自擂）。他说他为了质量控制听了前一天的播客。
And, you know, I just got the sense that I was tooting my own horn. A horn was being tooted and I indeed was both the tooter and the tootee. But I really got to thinking about that phrase. I would like to take two ticks to tutor you in the term to toot one's own horn. It is a strange phrase. It is a logically inconsistent phrase.
而且，你知道，我只是觉得我在吹我自己的号角。一个号角正在被吹响，而我确实既是吹号者也是被吹者。但我真的开始思考那个短语。我想花两秒钟来教你“吹自己的号角”这个词。这是一个奇怪的短语。这是一个逻辑上不一致的短语。
Tooting your own horn has an opposite number, and that is to be hoisted by one's own petard. To be hoisted by one's own petard actually makes sense. I mean, it is antiquated language. It was coined by Shakespeare, but a petard is a small bomb. So to be hoisted by one's own petard means to be blown up by a bomb blown into the air. It's a good phrase. A bomb normally meant for someone else blows up in your own face, lifts you high off the ground, Ashton Kutcher peeks out from behind the curtain. You've been hoisted. Great expression, I love it.
吹自己的号角有一个对等的说法，那就是“被自己的炸弹炸飞”（hoisted by one's own petard）。被自己的炸弹炸飞确实说得通。我的意思是，那是过时的语言。它是莎士比亚创造的，但 petard 是一种小炸弹。所以“被自己的炸弹炸飞”意味着被一颗炸弹炸飞，飞向空中。这是一个好短语。一颗本意给别人的炸弹炸到了你自己的脸上，把你高高举起，艾什顿·库彻（Ashton Kutcher）从幕后窥视。你被炸飞了。伟大的表达，我喜欢它。
But a horn is not meant for someone else to play. The expression "toot one's own horn" should instead center on a situation where you're forced to operate for yourself a device that was meant to be operated by another, right? So a more sensible alternative would be, hey, listen, I don't need to hold my own ladder, or, look, I'm not trying to cut my own hair over here, or, listen, I'm not trying to tuck myself in at night, or, far be it for me to hand start my own prop airplane, or I don't want to self-operate a two-handed cross cut saw, or I'm not one to spot myself while bench pressing. Or even you could stick with the musical, if you want. Hey, I'm not trying to play dueling banjos as a solo.
但号角不是给别人吹的。表达“吹自己的号角”应该改为集中在一个你被迫为自己操作一个本应由别人操作的设备的情况，对吧？所以一个更明智的选择可能是，嘿，听着，我不需要扶我自己的梯子，或者，看，我不是想在这里给自己剪头发，或者，听着，我不是想在晚上给自己盖被子，或者，更别提让我手动启动我自己的螺旋桨飞机，或者我不想自操作一个双人横切锯，或者我不是那种在卧推时给自己做保护的人。甚至如果你想的话，你可以坚持音乐的。嘿，我不是想独奏对决班卓琴。
And another thing, speaking of the musical. Ever think of Louis Armstrong in this situation? How does Louis Armstrong humble brag about his own promise? Can't say anything about not tooting his own horn. And toot? Really, toot? Did Miles Davis toot? Did Dizzy Gillespie toot? To toot one's own horn is a low form of self-aggrandizement. In fact, it should be more accurately seen as a form of self-mid-sizement at best.
还有一件事，说到音乐。想过路易斯·阿姆斯特朗（Louis Armstrong）在这种情况下吗？路易斯·阿姆斯特朗如何谦虚地吹嘘自己的前途？不能说什么不吹自己的号角。而且是“吹”？真的，吹？迈尔斯·戴维斯（Miles Davis）吹过吗？迪兹·吉莱斯皮（Dizzy Gillespie）吹过吗？吹自己的号角是一种低级的自我夸大。事实上，它应该更准确地被视为一种充其量是“自我中度夸大”。
Pesca does know where that phrase "tooting your own horn" comes from. It comes from a king. A king enters a room, there's trumpeters, there's fanfare. Others toot the horns for the king. Tooting your own horn in that situation would be very-- well, kind of pathetic.
佩斯卡确实知道“吹自己的号角”这个短语来自哪里。它来自一位国王。国王进入房间，有吹号手，有号角声。其他人为国王吹响号角。在这种情况下吹自己的号角会非常——嗯，有点可怜。
But Pesca says, today, those are not the horns we think of when we think of horns. The phrase does not hold. And he called for a moratorium. Or if you will,
但佩斯卡说，今天，那些不是我们想到号角时想到的号角。这个短语不成立。他呼吁暂停。或者如果你愿意，
A moratootium.
A moratootium（暂停吹号）。
So one more, right? On a Monday just after an outbreak of the Ebola virus hit-- serious story, right-- Pesca was talking about how the news had been covered on television. Over the weekend, the Sunday talk shows had been full of talk of a killer virus, maybe out of control. Was the public at risk? People were asking this over and over. And Pesca was parsing out what was said and what was not said.
所以再来一个，对吧？在一个星期一，就在埃博拉病毒爆发之后——严重的故事，对吧——佩斯卡正在谈论新闻是如何在电视上报道的。周末，周日的谈话节目充满了关于一种致命病毒的谈话，可能失控了。公众有风险吗？人们一次又一次地问这个问题。而佩斯卡正在解析什么被说了，什么没被说。
George Stephanopoulos was interviewing Dr. Tom Frieden. He runs the CDC. And I'm going to use the opportunity to play something that we sometimes play, talk show karaoke, wherein I assume the role of a guest on the talk show. We'll have the host ask the question and I'll answer the question how I wish the guest would have. Let's go to George Stephanopoulos' question.
乔治·斯特凡诺普洛斯（George Stephanopoulos）正在采访汤姆·弗里登（Tom Frieden）博士。他经营 CDC。我将利用这个机会播放我们有时会播放的东西，谈话节目卡拉OK，在其中我扮演谈话节目嘉宾的角色。我们让主持人提出问题，我将回答我希望嘉宾回答的方式。让我们进入乔治·斯特凡诺普洛斯的提问。
And, Dr. Frieden, as you know, a lot of anxiety here in the United States about the spread of Ebola, whether we're taking an unnecessary risk. A tweet that Donald Trump put out just the other day, he said that the US must immediately stop all flights from Ebola-infected countries, or the plague would start and spread inside our borders. Act fast. How do you respond to that?
而且，弗里登博士，正如你知道的，在美国对埃博拉病毒的传播有很多焦虑，我们是否正在承担不必要的风险。唐纳德·特朗普前几天发的一条推文，他说美国必须立即停止所有来自埃博拉感染国家的航班，否则瘟疫将在我们的边界内开始并蔓延。迅速采取行动。你对此有何回应？
I'm glad you asked, George. First, a little bit about myself. I, Tom Frieden, have a master's degree in public health from Columbia. I did my residency at Yale. I've been an epidemiologist in the field for many years. I've contained outbreaks of measles and typhoid and tuberculosis, as you know. For the last four years, I've been with the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention as its director. It is the foremost facility of its kind in the world. So that's about me.
我很高兴你问，乔治。首先，关于我自己的一点点。我，汤姆·弗里登，拥有哥伦比亚大学的公共卫生硕士学位。我在耶鲁大学完成了住院实习。我是一名在实地工作多年的流行病学家。正如你知道的，我控制了麻疹、伤寒和结核病的爆发。在过去的四年里，我一直担任疾病控制和预防中心（CDC）的主任。它是世界上同类设施中最卓越的。所以那是关于我。
Now let me tell you a little bit about Donald Trump and his qualifications. Donald Trump, the man whose opinions on contagious diseases you asked me to comment on, is in real estate. He also owned the New Jersey Generals, the Eastern Airline Shuttle, the Miss USA Pageant, and was executive producer of the reality TV show The Apprentice. A catchphrase from that show, The Apprentice, is contained in the following Trump quote about comedian Rosie O'Donnell. Quote, "I'd look her right that fat ugly face that hers and I'd say, Rosie, you're fired."
现在让我告诉你一点关于唐纳德·特朗普和他的资格。唐纳德·特朗普，那个你问我评论其对传染病意见的人，是做房地产的。他还拥有新泽西将军队、东方航空班机、美国小姐选美大赛，并且是真人秀节目《学徒》的执行制作人。该节目的一个口头禅，《学徒》，包含在以下关于喜剧演员罗西·奥唐纳（Rosie O'Donnell）的特朗普引语中。引述，“我会看着她那张肥胖丑陋的脸，我会说，罗西，你被解雇了。”
An interesting coincidence from both of our biographies, I lived in India for five years, where I fought disease, Donald Trump owned a Casino that he called the Taj Mahal, took it into bankruptcy. Also, Donald Trump unsuccessfully sued for $5 million after proving that his father was not, in fact, an orangutan. And while all of this does go to Donald Trump's overall credibility, in the specific area of scientific credibility, let me remind you that Richard Besser has called Donald Trump's mistaken beliefs on the causes of autism, quote, "shameful."
从我们两个的传记中有一个有趣的巧合，我在印度住了五年，在那里我抗击疾病，唐纳德·特朗普拥有一个他称之为泰姬陵的赌场，并使其破产。此外，唐纳德·特朗普在证明他的父亲实际上不是红毛猩猩后，不成功地起诉了500万美元。虽然所有这些都涉及唐纳德·特朗普的整体可信度，但在科学可信度的具体领域，让我提醒你，理查德·贝瑟（Richard Besser）称唐纳德·特朗普对自闭症原因的错误信念是，引述，“可耻的”。
Now, who is Richard Besser, you ask? Ah, that you'd ask that, because not 45 seconds ago, here was your introduction of this discussion that we're having right now.
现在，你问谁是理查德·贝瑟？啊，你问得好，因为就在45秒前，这是你对我们现在正在进行的这场讨论的介绍。
And joining us now from Atlanta, the head of the Centers for Disease Control, Dr. Tom Frieden, and our own, Dr. Richard Besser, also veteran of the CDC--
现在加入我们的是来自亚特兰大，疾病控制中心负责人，汤姆·弗里登博士，以及我们自己的，理查德·贝瑟博士，也是 CDC 的老兵——
Richard Besser is your network's chief health and medical editor. He said that following Trump's advice, quote, "can kill children." So, again, your question is, what do I think of Donald Trump's tweet? I just want to go back to a little bit about my biography again. I have over 200 peer-reviewed articles published in scientific journals.
理查德·贝瑟是你们网络的首席健康和医学编辑。他说，听从特朗普的建议，引述，“可能会杀死孩子。”所以，再一次，你的问题是，我对唐纳德·特朗普的推文怎么看？我只是想再回到我的一点点传记。我有200多篇经同行评审的文章发表在科学期刊上。
But, again, the question for me to respond to Donald Trump's tweet that the US should stop all flights from Ebola-infected countries, so I guess I'll say this in response to that question, George. I should answer Donald Trump's take on science as soon as Donald Trump is asked to comment on my opinion that he is a pompous, overbearing, ignorant windbag who lusts for attention the way a meth-addicted prostitute lusts for his next fix. And to use an analogy from my profession, the media acts as an unwashed Petri dish that allows this particular nasty virus to thrive. Perhaps a less incendiary way of me putting this would be to say--
但是，再一次，让我回答唐纳德·特朗普关于美国应该停止所有来自埃博拉感染国家的航班的推文的问题，所以我猜我会在回应那个问题时这样说，乔治。我应该尽快回答唐纳德·特朗普对科学的看法，就像唐纳德·特朗普被要求评论我对他的看法一样：他是一个自负、傲慢、无知的吹牛大王，像一个吸食冰毒的妓女渴望他的下一次固定物一样渴望关注。用我专业的一个类比，媒体作为一个未清洗的培养皿，使这种特别讨厌的病毒得以茁壮成长。也许我这样说的一种不太煽动的方式是——
Well, Ebola's scary. And it's understandable that with a deadly disease, people are concerned. But the plain truth is that we can stop Ebola. We know how to control it, hospital infection control and stopping it at the source in Africa.
好吧，埃博拉很可怕。并且可以理解，对于一种致命的疾病，人们很担心。但简单的事实是我们可以停止埃博拉。我们知道如何控制它，医院感染控制和在非洲源头处停止它。
So that last part, that's what Dr. Frieden did say. It was probably smarter than what I should have said. Anyway, that guy is too important to pick media fights with Donald Trump. He already has one seemingly unstoppable plague to wrestle with.
所以最后一部分，那是弗里登博士确实说的。它可能比我应该说的更聪明。无论如何，那个家伙太重要了，不能挑选与唐纳德·特朗普的媒体斗争。他已经有一个看似不可阻挡的瘟疫要搏斗了。
If words really were magic, in all fairness, Donald Trump would vanish from the earth in a puff of smoke after that. The podcast is called The Gist, Mike Pesca. It's free, it's daily, five days a week. Find it at Slate.com, or anywhere you find your podcasts.
如果词语真的是魔法，公道地说，唐纳德·特朗普在说那句话后会变成一团烟雾消失在地球上。那个播客叫《要点》（The Gist），迈克·佩斯卡。它是免费的，它是每天的，每周五天。在 Slate.com 找到它，或者任何你找到播客的地方。
[MUSIC - "DONALD TRUMP" BY LICH]
[音乐 - LICH 的“DONALD TRUMP”]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Production help from Louise Sullivan. Seth Lind is our director of operations. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Kimberly Henderson as our office coordinator. Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Rob Geddes.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔洪（Ben Calhoun）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）一起。我们这一集的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。路易丝·沙利文（Louise Sullivan）的制作帮助。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的业务运营经理。金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）是我们的办公室协调员。今天来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）的研究帮助。来自罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddes）的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Jake Halpern's book about debt that I talked about at the beginning of the program is called Bad Paper-- Inside the Secret World of Debt Collectors. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr Torey Malatia, who says it is all right if people want to bring their dogs to the office.
杰克·霍尔珀恩关于债务的那本书我在节目开始时谈到过，叫《不良票据——债务催收者的秘密世界》。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由 PRX，公共广播交换中心发送给公共广播电台。谢谢，像往常一样，我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr Torey Malatia），他说如果人们想带狗去办公室是可以的。
You just have to train them right and give them pants.
你只需要好好训练它们，给它们穿上裤子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "ABRA-CA-DABRA" BY THE DEFRANCO FAMILY]
[音乐 - THE DEFRANCO FAMILY 的“ABRA-CA-DABRA”]